it is the one-year anniversary of the
january sixth trump riots we are going
to have a little bit of coverage of that
later today we're also going to carry on
tomorrow's show we'll have some clips
from joe biden's uh statement his speech
today about that one year anniversary
very very heavily placing a lot of the
blame on donald trump did joe biden
today
but we'll talk about that later and
tomorrow there's so much else to get to
and i'm going to jump right into it as
many of you know any opportunity that i
have
to clear up confusion or misinformation
disinformation propaganda or bad math
and statistics those are opportunities
that i relish and unfortunately
the opportunity we have today is to look
at a clip from republican senator rand
paul
who
to some people very convincingly made an
argument yesterday
not only against vaccine mandates but
against vaccines at all when it comes to
coronavirus and so we're going to look
at this clip there's a bunch of
different concepts here that are
relevant and that are important so i'm
going to be making notes of each of the
aspects of what he says that need to be
discussed see if you can pick out the
fallacious claims and then we're going
to talk about it in more detail let's
take a look
and so what we're dealing with is now a
different disease and it needs to be
treated differently we need to get rid
of the hysteria but the people who are
promoting this stereo work for the
government i mean this is dr fauci's
fault largely worse because he's still
hysterically talking about mandates and
shutting people down and not letting
people fly and blaming the unvaccinated
everybody's getting this vaccinated
unvaccinated in fact the majority of
people in the hospital now are
vaccinated because almost everybody's
been vaccinated
now
that is a lot of disinformation but
there's one really funny thing
at the end of what rand paul says
he actually gets to something that's
really important in understanding the
effectiveness and efficacy of vaccines
which is he says
because almost everyone is vaccinated
now that's not actually true in the
united states we have a pathetically
embarrassingly low vaccination rate
relative to so many other countries
specifically because of republicans and
trump supporters who have one of the
lowest vaccination rates in any country
that has widespread access to vaccines
you can look at countries that don't yet
have widespread access to vaccines and
say well they have lower rates than
republicans yes but they have no access
to vaccines
among groups so if you look at
you know uh
spanish right wingers and you know
whatever group you want american
republicans are arguably
and i think
probably undoubtedly although
right up there the least uh vaccinated
group among any group in
countries with widespread vaccine access
and by far the most unvaccinated group
in the united states but rand paul gets
to something really important
in a country
where everyone is vaccinated
everybody with covid would be vaccinated
that doesn't really tell you anything
about how good the vaccines are at
preventing illness at all
preventing symptomatic illness
preventing serious illness
hospitalization or death i mean think
about that
no vaccine is 100
and thus
the more vaccinated a country is
the higher number of people who are
vaccinated that are going to get that
disease it doesn't actually tell you how
much better off you are
being vaccinated than not
if you get to 100 vaccinated every case
will be in a vaccinated person what we
need to be looking at are the outcomes
and the relative risk imagine a country
with 99 percent vaccination
and 90 percent of the hospitalizations
are in that one percent that's not
vaccinated even though
uh uh you you have this high level of
vaccination you would still say you're
way better off vaccinated than on
vaccinated so let's look at some data
along those lines um when we look at um
we can look at a bunch of different
places let's start with kentucky you
look at
hospitalizations in kentucky as of
yesterday okay
45 inpatient hospitalizations
76 were unvaccinated whereas 24 percent
were vaccinated even though the majority
of kentucky residents are vaccinated
three-quarters of those in the hospital
did not have the vaccine the relative
risk of being unvaccinated is
significant okay
you look at critical care in icu
patients 11 of them
100 of them are unvaccinated
so even though rand paul might look and
say most people are vaccinated and the
numbers are going crazy look at the 11
people in an icu i think this is
admitted yesterday
100 of them are unvaccinated and if you
look at the six patients that are on
ventilators
none of those people are vaccinated this
is what we're hearing anecdotally from
emergency room doctors the people with
three vaccines are having very mild
illness and don't need to be in the
hospital generally speaking there's
obviously exceptions to everything let's
look next at whoa that's a picture of me
don't know where that came from let's
look at ontario in ontario you have
three charts here i'll describe them for
people that are not um that are not
watching that are just listening today
if you look at cases cases are going up
among everybody now these these are
per capita so this is important to
understand this is per capita the
leftmost graph coveted cases you see
that the rate among the unvaccinated is
significantly higher
than among those with at least two doses
it's going up for everybody because
omicron is so contagious now look at
who's in the hospital
the gap
between unvaccinated and vaccinated in
the hospital is incredible
in ontario among the unvaccinated the
hospitalization rate is about 550
per million inhabitants whereas the rate
among the vaccinated is only about a
hundred you have a five and a half times
higher rate of being in the hospital if
you're unvaccinated and then if you look
at icu the numbers are even more
stunning um icu occupancy among
unvaccinated people is about 140 per
million it's only about 10 for those who
are vaccinated so that puts you
14 times higher risk of ending up in the
icu if you are not vaccinated
last illustration here is from new york
city
looking at new york city here uh you see
this is just cases cases are going up
for everybody but the purple line is
cases per hundred thousand among the
unvaccinated it's about fifty five
hundred per hundred thousand
cases among the vaccinated are about
three hundred okay uh
15 x or so higher so rand paul
is
mathematically correct in that
increasingly as more people get
vaccinated
more and more of the cases will be among
the vaccinated that's just simple math
it's base rates
uh but
the rate of hospitalization
um
intubation
and death continues to be dramatically
higher among those who have not been
vaccinated this it's this this is why
this is around the world there's no
country in which this is not being
observed so very dangerous
disinformation from rand paul which a
lot of these fox news viewer sycophant
types grasp onto for dear life and
uncritically repeat
understand the math very very important
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when i use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say i'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up i can delete that
virtual card so i know i'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video